when i think of christmas
i think of you
remember the snow angels unorthodox and
adults
about how it's never home
unless you're here don't matter how deep
the snow
don't matter how cold it goes i've
already made it home
[Music]
because you're here still at the kids
they believing that we're grown hands on
money gap underneath
[Music]
[Music]
christmas
[Music]
i think of nothing but nothing
i think of you
[Music]
rewriting my memories creating new
history
and the season feels new to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
of christmas i think of
you
hi i'm kristen stewart i'm mackenzie
davis from the cast of happiest season
merry christmas merry christmas
on christmas why am
i out of control
[Music]
give me forgiveness
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
blame me don't blame me to
[Music]
blame it on it
[Music]
and praise her and fixing and coming and
cupid and donner and bliss and don't
worry about rudolph cause he never
listens and don't get me started and you
blame me on christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cause i just can't keep
[Music]
follow
[Music]
[Music]
while i'm back
[Music]
hi i'm allison brie from our family to
yours
happy holidays
[Music]
laughing all the way
making spirits bright what fun it is
oh what fun it
[Music]
the is oh what fun it is
[Music]
[Music]
oh what fun it is
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone i'm aubrey plaza
and i'm dan levy uh we know this year
has been a lot
so we hope our new film happiest season
brings you some much needed holiday
cheer
something by the way that got me feeling
something new
that i felt before the last 24th
i'll always take december way over
summer june
cause i'd rather be setting up the tree
or with my family
making memories like a silver screen do
it's a classic
that we make brand new
the only time of year the kids are
singing cause
nick is in town
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we all got our traditions but we love
breaking the rules
drowning all our thoughts grandma's
eggnog
there's nothing on my wish list that
hasn't come true
wouldn't change a thing i got everything
or with my family making memories like a
silver scream do
it's a classic that we make brand new
[Music]
the only time
[Music]
is me
[Music]
the only time of year the kids are
singing
nick is in town around
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
hi there um i'm cleo duval co-writer and
director of happiest season
and i'm mary holland happy holidays
somebody broke your heart
under a christmas tree
so many fallen stars
give them back to me have i been
good
[Music]
you're the only girl i've got on my list
i write your name i know it's foolish
but i changed the feeling cause you keep
me dreaming
that i could make your mind this season
make your mind
[Music]
[Music]
lights glowing in the trees
will you dance with me
the only girl i've got on my list
i like your name i know it's foolish
but i changed the feeling cause you keep
me dreaming
[Music]
i just wanna make you mine
it's like it's gonna lead you straight
to me
i just wanna make you mine
[Music]
you're the only girl i've got on my list
i write your name i know it's foolish
but i changed the feeling cause you keep
me dreaming
that i could make your mind make your
[Music]
mind
[Music]
make your mind make your mind
[Music]
this season